und wieder geht es um außerirdische
leben obwohl hier auf der erde geforscht
mit forscher haben wohl die ältesten
fossilen auf unserem heimatplaneten
gefunden und will den fast so alt wie
die erde
das finde ich wirklich eine unglaubliche
entdeckung denn dass es bedeutend wie
ich meine für die suche nach dem leben
auf dem mars
warum jetzt wirklich vom feinsten witzen
herzlich willkommen sind wohl wirklich
die ältesten verfielen auf der erde 377
bis zu 4 29 milliarden jahre alt war
das ist wirklich ziemlich bahn brechen
denn es bedeutet dass es schon kurz nach
der entstehung unseres planeten leben
auf dem grab die erde entstand nämlich
vor um 4 5 milliarden jahren also aus
heutiger perspektive kurz davor sind
röhren und farben förmige strukturen die
die forscher im judo ag zug
grünsteingürtel im nördlichen kanada
gefunden haben diese strukturen
entstanden anheizen unterseeischen
quellen
zuvor waren die ältesten funde von leben
3,7 milliarden jahre alt und wurden in
altem grönländischen eis gefunden
chemische zusammensetzung die mineralien
die dort gefunden worden und die
struktur der kunde streichen zur lebt
vorher wiederum hatte man noch funde aus
der westaustralischen pilbara wüste als
älteste funde gesehen sie waren 3 5
milliarden jahre alt es werden also
immer ältere versteinerung gefunden die
auf leben auf der erde hindeuten sie
zeigen nicht nur für uns hier das leben
auf der erde schon sehr lange existiert
sondern in dieser erkenntnis steckt noch
viel mehr wenn sich die pfunde wirklich
als die frühesten organismen auf unsere
erde herausstellen dann bedeutet dass
das leben schon sehr früh und unter sehr
schlechten bedingungen entstehen kann
und daraus ergeben sich mehrere
schlüssel meine ich dürften
wenn dem so ist heißt das dass das leben
quasi ein normalzustand im universum ist
schon wenn die bedingung noch sehr
unwirklich das heißt besonders heiß oder
kalt oder trocken oder oder oder sind
dann entsteht schon leben für die
astrobiologie heißt auf nahezu auf jedem
exoplaneten der in der habitablen also
lebensfreundlichen zone
um seinen paradesturm kreis könnte
gezwungenermaßen quasi schon sehr früh
leben entstehen zeiten unser universum
ist voll von nehmen es ist wirklich nur
noch eine frage der zeit wann wir auch
leben stoßen wir wissen so immer besser
wonach wir suchen müssen und das sind
exoplaneten mit wasser in der habitablen
zone wenn sie die gefundenen
mikroorganismen das erste leben neben
heißen quellen entsteht spielt es
eigentlich keine rolle welche anderen
bedingungen der planet effekt
gesteinsplanet mit wasser würde bedeuten
dass es dort auch leben gibt drittens
und jetzt kommt's auf dem mars muss es
leben geben wenn sogar in der
trockensten wüste der welt der
atacama-wüste mikroorganismen überleben
können dazu mehr in einem der nächsten
videos dann ist es fast schon zwingend
dass wir auf dem mars leben finden und
wird ich finde es eine wahrlich positive
aussicht wenn wir entdecken dass das
universum ein riesiges biotop ist wo das
leben an allen ecken und enden entsteht
für mich würde das ganze so viel mehr
sinn machen
damit wäre die frage wofür eigentlich
der ganze aufwand und wo mit dem
universum und los für mich jedenfalls
schon ein wenig beantwortet das ganze
ist natürlich spekulation aber ich finde
nicht ganz unwahrscheinlich ja mehr
klicks ein science fiction bekommt ihr
nur regelmäßig nämlich täglich wenn er
mir hier ein auge auf wo drückt oder so
ähnlich und mir danach noch einen auch
die glocke gibt dann verpasst er
wirklich nicht und hier geht es zu einem
weiteren video zum thema außerirdisches
leben einfach draufklicken und wenn er
auch nicht klickt dann sage ich
bis dann bleib dran mache ich aber auch
wenn es nicht tut